all the best foods are eaten with your
hands everyone knows that and people who
don't know that are wrong I've never had
a Nigerian food I've always wanted to
try it I'm excited let me flow chewy
which I really like
it's like spaghetti it does like better
than spaghetti like if sweet potato
fries had a cousin and that cousin was
better the lady back here wonderfully
explained that very customary to do that
which makes sense if you're eating from
your hand okay air pro I just chew it I
watched other people do it all the times
in America we get to fill you two just
like fork and knives kind of shoving it
into your mouth all the time whereas
like that's it's more of like a full-on
experience all the best foods are even
with your hands their fishing nets are
detect oh whoa I get that too it's like
tangy sharp
it tastes like tofu ish kind of like
like really starchy over cooked rice I'm
like a mashed potato but with this
together has so much more flavor I love
all meats on sticks I've never had a
meat on stick I didn't like just like a
powdery flavor on the outside very beef
jerky ish also it's one of those things
where it's like it is hot but as you
keep eating it you just kind of burn off
your like feelers a bit so it's easier
to eat it it's like addicting like hot
cheetos this is really opening up my
sinuses it snapped me out of my food
coma
a lot of like like salty and spicy you
like the Midwestern in me want to get
like a big ass roll and just like don't
get I'm not a big seafood guy but this
is like a good level of fishiness I also
can tell that they wrote the pepper
before hand which is really great give
it some great like deep flavor I'm
sweating Wow
they like hits you in a wave of heat I
can't even speak it's kind of comforting
a comforting brochure comforting yeah
this was delicious I had a great time
eating all that and I wish it was more
mainstream so I could eat that jollof
rice anywhere it was so good
a lot of our cultures around the world
especially food wise have seven from
there and I feel like it's just what a
great experience that we're looking out
on
[Music]